40 million americans are now fully  vaccinated against coven 19.  as with other vaccines there can be side  effects common symptoms can include  pain redness and swelling at the  injection site  and some skin rashes have also been  reported but doctors say don't panic  anything from a headache to a feeling  of muscle aches or fatigue  and i'm just feeling maybe even chills  and fever  signs that your immune system is  responding to the vaccine  data so far from the cdc suggests three  groups are reporting stronger side  effects  that includes women people who already  had covet and younger adults  severe allergic reactions from the  vaccine are rare  cdc is recommending anyone who gets the  cobia vaccine  be monitored on sites